okay I bill hader said that you were
responsible for his casting because you
said it in interview I was yeah yeah
then wolf are basically just got me the
job so yeah he just want to be in the
movie and I'm like alright how it
happened walk ya know they asked him in
an interview who'd he want play and he
said me for the second movie and they
called me up so he's really powerful
crazy it's not awesome
so what was it did you guys spend time
together to kind of pick each other's
mannerism Rick well bill can kind of
just watch the movie and see what I did
it was easy for him so but you know we
had a period of some days where we just
hung out in his trailer and talked you
know whatever just [ __ ] around for a
while hung out so yeah I mean we're good
we're good buds I I love that you're
kind of starring in all the films that
stranger things with influenced by yeah
it's a crazy coincidence where do you
think that being in stranger things has
helped and it helping you beyond these
people's mind whether I think so i think
you know i don't i don't really know i
hope that my acting like speaks for
itself
of course it but yeah I have fun with
everything I just wonder if there like
we soften in the Ghostbusters Tosh
totally yeah yeah I guess well yeah I
guess we'll see what comes with that
yeah yeah what's the Ghostbusters update
what's it gonna be like how excited are
I'm really excited it's genuinely a
really beautiful film we're really
excited this pretty we'll see it's
really that's really faithful to the
losers
we made an oath I swear if it isn't dead
if it ever comes back
we'll come back to you we didn't stop it
now it's chapter two picks up all the
losers are kind of separated and
stranger things the [ __ ] the last season
kind of leaves with everybody separating
our Mike an 11-page in each other I
don't know yeah they're beating each
other yeah yeah I don't know i guess i
guess you know when if we do come back
like be interesting to see how that
relationship works because i don't see
them really like breaking up if they've
gone through all this stuff so I guess
yeah we'll see what happens
herro TP
[Music]